dann haben ist luca seit wochen schon
nicht mehr richtig auf e mails auf
meinem kanal hier reagiert habe dachte
ich mir heute ist es mal wieder soweit
dass wir unsere gehirnzellen zerstören
von daher würde ich sagen fanggeräten
mit einem kühlschrank den er hier
forderten eingeblendet und zwar es ist
ja ein amerikanischer kühlschrank links
der eisschrank rechts der kühlschrank er
hat das allerdings nicht als kühlschrank
beschrieben sondern als amerikanische
schrank perfekt kannst du alle deine
kühleren verstauen
das hier ist denn jetzt die befehle und
ihr seht schon dass dort jemand
wahrscheinlich ein skateboard verkauft
in den titel diese anzeige schreibt er
allerdings kette bowl mit design für 15
euro
und das hier ist auch schon der nächste
film lieben freunde hier sind wir glaube
ich alle dass das ein rasierer ist er
nicht das ganze allerdings haare
schneiden ich würde sagen bevor ihr eure
produkte verkauft solltet ihr euch
lieber mal was anderes kaufen das ist so
krass wie viel werbung ich für diese
website mache ohne einen cent von
hinzubekommen
allerdings hier schon direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten ebay kleinanzeigen fällt
und ich doch wir sind uns alle einig
dass es ein meerschweinchen bzw
hasenstall ist die sache ist allerdings
dass er das ganze als meerschweinchen
hassen stahl betitelt
ja
genau das was du gesagt hast ist das
beim nächsten die befehle haben sich
käufer und verkäufer bereits geeinigt
und die person die das produkt kaufen
möchte fragt ihn hallo das ist schön
welche adresse viele grüße der verkäufer
antwortet hasse das hasselter platz
detmold re wirken sie wohnen also im
rewe welche uhrzeit ja ich wohne
tiefkühler also
[Musik]
ja
wir treffen uns dann nicht weil ich dir
das darüber geben will
du kommst dann einfach zu mir weil ich
da wohne hier verkauft eine person eine
spülmaschine beziehungsweise in seinen
worten eine spülmaschine ab
frag mich wirklich absolut gar nichts
mehr und das jetzt auch stark und zwar
fragt der käufer wo wäre der abzuholen
und der verkäufer antwortet abzuholen
man sagt zuerst halo 4 5 790
höflichkeits land und das ist so circa
die größte ahlmann antwort die ich je
gesehen habe auf ebay verkauft seine
person einen fahrradträger und ein ebay
nutzer beziehungsweise interessant
schreibt ich biete 150 euro wenn ich
ihnen heute noch abholen kann liebe
grüße markus hallo tut mir leid ist zu
spontan aber wir können gerne einen
anderen termin ausmachen bitte ich
brauche als meine frau verlässt mich
sonst bitte helfen sie mir ich bin
gefahr seine flotte hof geschickt kein
foto und seinem auto sondern von sich
selbst und die person schreibt doch
einfach nur
das erinnert mich an seinem chat verlauf
von mir und meiner mom heute morgen und
zwar war sie im supermarkt und hat mir
einfach so rennen geschrieben lukas
solche die milch mitbringen ich denke
mir nur so mama erstens ich trink keine
milch zweitens bin ich gerade in köln
habe ich trotzdem mir dass sie so
einfach mal ein foto schicken sie auch
einzel von sich geschickt
danke die milch würde ich daneben
konnten wir allerdings die auch schon
zum nächsten ebay kleinanzeigen feld und
zwar seht ihr schon jemand verkauft sein
fahrrad in einer weißen farbe das ist
allerdings keine normale weiße farbe
sondern das ist ein bmx in
toilettenpapier farbe und das hier ist
auch schon direkt der nächste ich bin
eine person verkauft ein lego city 7
2007 feuerwehrchef darum geht es
allerdings nicht denn ein potenzieller
interessent fragte ich hätte eine frage
der verkäufer antwortet haye klar fragt
ruhig okay ich habe eigentlich eine
allgemeine frage dass keine fragen zu
dem produkt das ich hoffe sie sind mir
jetzt nicht böse und vergeht es im
folgenden ich bin momentan auf der suche
nach nicht fehlen die ich für ein
kunstprojekt drauf und wollte die daher
fragen sie zufälligerweise zähne haben
diesen verkaufen könnte nicht weiter
sieht anfang gesetzt corina damit könnte
ich mir vorstellen dass es sehr sehr
schwer 11 so etwas spielt sie eine
single zu kommen und momentan bleibt mir
nichts anderes übrig als rumtragen ich
freue mich auf ihre anfang und das ist
sehr komisch
auf der anderen seite wenn es für ein
kunstprojekt ist würde ich auch glaube
ich bei leuten fragen die lego sieht die
feuerwehr schiffe verkaufen weil die ja
dann vermutlich unsere kinder haben und
was macht man sonst nicht sehen kann man
legt die hand unters kopfkissen aber
danach schmeißt man ja weg oder
die zahnfee es auch so ein generelles
den iwf schon direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten der kleinanzeigenteil uns heute
schon das ist ein porzellan gepard
allerdings schreibt die person in den
titel ein porzellan gerhard irgendwie
hat rede
luca fuchs bis hier verkauft eine person
einen neuwertigen vogelkäfig der erst
drei monate alt er sondern auf dem foto
man sieht halt den käfig allerdings
steht dort auch home home sweet home
sweet home quatsch das heißt home home
sweet beim nächsten liebefeld verkauft
eine person ein smartphone und ein
interessent schreibt ihm morgen die ich
biete ihnen 30 euro inklusive versand
liebe grüße servus tut mir leid unter 50
euro gebe ich jetzt nicht ab dann
natürliches an die wand dann legen sie
es lieber an die wand liebe grüße und
dann hat er das handy halt wirklich an
die wand genagelt apropos wand das hier
hat überhaupt nichts mit einer wand zu
tun denn es ist ein top tv schrank ich
habe keine ahnung warum die da so
posieren aber ich weiß auch gar nicht
was das jetzt mit einer wand zu tun hat
bei diesem ebay verkauft eine person 100
euro itunes guthaben karte und eine
person fragt ihn paypal
nein was denn nur abholung wo steht
alles in der anzeige wenn du mir den
gutscheindienst hast du einen monat lang
mit meiner schwester videotelefonieren
sie machen alles was du willst gebe dir
sofort ihren aber damit du siehst dass
es echt dass wir beide haben das schon
mal gemacht
okay das für ein bescheuertes
gegenangebot und hier beim nächsten die
bfl seht ihr schon dass eine person
anscheinend eine jack wolfskin jacke
verkaufte die person stellt jacke
allerdings nicht als jack wolfskin jacke
ebay sondern als jack wolfgang jacke
übergangs jacke mit kapuze größe l
beziehungsweise 48 für 35 euro
wer kennt sie nicht jacke wolfgang
jacken und hier verkauft eine mutter
wirklich ganz süß selbst genähte masken
sie hat sich allerdings vertippt und
schreibt in den titel selbst genähte
damen maultaschen
ja wer kennt nicht die selbst genähten
genähte maultaschen
glück die maultaschen ich nicht hier
schreibt eine person morgen wo ist die
adresse 20 minuten später schickte noch
mal ein fragezeichen hinter her und
achteinhalb stunden später nochmal zwei
augen
daraufhin antwortet dann die personen
guten abend wann könnten sie die sachen
abholen wenn du in meiner nähe lebt
werde ich jetzt kommen ich lebe in einem
gemüse sagt das ist so ein fall
da frage ich mich dann wirklich nichts
mehr
häufig dass ich mich nichts mehr frage
aber in mein mund ist gerade auch eine
schüssel reingeflogen habe ich gesehen
und es schmeckt ziemlich schlau und beim
nächsten mal fällt hier seht ihr schon
dass man wirklich absolut gar nichts
erkennen kann es ist ein komplett
schwarzes leeres foto das liegt daran
dass die person wirklich auch gar nichts
verkauft und in der beschreibung steht
wenn jemand was gegen nichts tauschen
möchte gerne
also man kann entweder nichts kaufen
oder man kann nichts gegen nichts
tauschen
das angebot aller zeiten kommen nun
allerdings zum längsten ebay chat
verlauf glaube ich den wir je hatten in
einer episode und zwar geht es hier um
und meinen riesenteil die 180 cm guten
tag ist der teddy noch da liebe grüße ja
der ist doch zu haben für 45 würde ich
ihn jetzt holen 50 euro ich bin
glücklich habe leider nur noch 45 euro
muss relativ lange fahren ab kommt schon
ich habe damals 120 euro bezahlt ich hab
noch 48 euro hat wirklich nichts mehr
ich bin azubi mensch ja kommen dann bin
ich ihn los ich bin auch ein armer
student ohne einkommen momentan okay ich
war jetzt gleich los muss doch den
spanngurt besorgen ich komme mit
motorrad ich schreibe dir wenig los
fahren mit dem motorrad davon muss ich
dann aber ein foto machen hab schon 120
oder 150 hat es drauf gehabt aber 180
wird lustig vor allem bei 40 minuten
fahren tara haha ja gut bekommen wir
schon hin und das ist dann das foto was
er gemacht hat
der typ ist dann wirklich mit einem
motorrad den teddy abholen gefahren und
hat den teddy dann hinten auf seinem
motorrad draufgesetzt wir nun allerdings
zu diesem ebay fehler und zwar seht ihr
schon dass dort eine couch mit ein
bisschen unordnung zu verkaufen ist
allerdings ist nicht die couch zu
verkaufen sondern die
hinterlassenschaften vom kinde date und
in der beschreibung schreibt er dann
hallo hier fleißigen quarantäne ich
biete hier das chaos vom geflohenen date
an zu verschenken sind ein t shirt der
marke superdry mit leichtem
schweißgeruch gemischt mit ihnen der max
duschgel riecht etwas streng gewöhnt man
sich aber daran ein paar schwarze
ballerina socken nach dem geschehen von
letzter land schätzungsweise größe 45
und ein paar übrig gebliebene maoam
zweimal kohle einmal tierschutz oder
einmal zitrone also schlag zu bin bereit
die dinge zweck sicherheitsabstand aus
dem fenster zu werfen
und jetzt meine lieben freunde kommen
wir wieder zu einigen reimen die ich
vorbereitet habe und das hier ist direkt
der erste ebay raimund zwar rose sind
rot ich stehe am grab weil mein
geliebter kitchenaid pürierstab ja du
stehst auf geballert dann sei doch so
frei und kaufen die den knaller
atombombe raider 2 rosen sind rot in dem
weg die hand du verdeckt die tasche mit
band ich wollte meinen hund kreuzen das
dauerte es ewig doch jetzt habe ich mein
labrador meerschweinchen männlich mit
käfig gta ist das beste spiel ich hoffe
ihr versteht das verkaufte 2 ps2 spiele
ganze auto und rannte auto san andreas
und an der stelle wirklich das heutige
wir jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn euch die heutige
episode ebay fans mal wieder gefallen
hat das gern einen daumen hoch runter
die medien schreiben in die kommentare
was euer lieblings spiel ist was es was
ist euer lieblings spiel gerade lass
mich in ruhe
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
schon im auto meine lieben freunde hier
oben für die 1 mai die eingeblendet wenn
er darauf könnte meinen kann kostenlos
abonniert verpasst keine videos mehr
wenn ich schon abonnenten klickt dann
auf die glocke der name kommt eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich im neuen
video hochladen und hier ist ein video
verlinkt das soeben auf meinem 2 kanal
online gegangen ist da habe ich nämlich
auf umstrittene youtuber produkte
reagiert
also klickt das geht an